After 10 years, Apple has finally updated
the design of their MacBook Air with the brand
new 2018 model, and from the looks of it,
it’s the best choice if you’re trying
to buy an entry-level MacBook, right?
Well not exactly.
The new MacBook Air has some pretty serious
shortcomings compared to last years’ 13”
MacBook Pro, which is now on sale for $100
off for a limited time on B&H, so it’s exactly
the same price as the new MacBook Air.
We think the 2017 MacBook Pro is the better
choice, but of course, both laptops have their
strengths, so let’s take a look at what
the Pro does better first.
Even though the new MacBook Air finally has
a retina display with the same resolution
that the Pro has, it’s actually much worse.
The new Air is rated at 300 nits of brightness
but LaptopMag measured only 234.
In comparison, the 2017 MacBook Pro is rated
at 500 nits and it measured in at 458 nits,
that’s almost twice as bright!
You can see both laptops at maximum brightness,
and the difference is perfectly clear.
Not only that, but the MacBook Pro supports
P3 wide-color gamut, so it’s much more color
accurate than the new Air.
Another drawback to the new Air is the lack
of performance.
The Pro scored quite a bit better in Geekbench
4’s CPU test, and we saw the same thing
in Cinebench R15’s CPU test.
For graphics, the Pro was 50% faster in Geekbench
4 and ____ faster in Cinebench’s graphics
test.
Now I know, that’s why it’s called the
Pro, but you can buy the Pro for literally
the same exact price as the Air.
Also, the new MacBook Air only comes with
a 30W power adapter, while the Pro comes with
a 61W power adapter, so the battery on the
Pro should charge almost twice as fast.
The trackpad on the MacBook Pro is also significantly
larger even though the keyboards are practically
the same size, so you’ve got more room to
navigate.
One thing we noticed is that the speakers
on the 2017 Pro are actually better than the
ones on the new Air, just listen for yourself.
Based on everything we’ve compared so far,
the MacBook Pro looks like the obvious choice,
but now let’s talk about some of the ways
the MacBook Air is better.
The Air is rated at 12 hours of battery life
while the Pro only gets 10.
It’s also more portable, weighing in at
2.75 pounds, a quarter of a pound less than
the Pro.
Even though they’re basically the same size
if you look at them from above, the Air definitely
looks thinner from the side thanks to the
wedge shape.
Interestingly, the Air is slightly thicker
at the wide end, but much thinner near the
front.
The MacBook Pro’s front edge tends to dig
into your wrist after long typing sessions,
but the Air actually slopes downward so it’s
much more comfortable to type on.
Not only that, but the Air has updated third-generation
butterfly keys that include a silicon barrier
to protect the key switches debris, which
caused issues with a rare number of older-gen
keyboards like on the 2017 MacBook Pro.
The Air also gets Touch ID, which is really
nice for logging into your account and buying
things with Apple Pay.
The Pro doesn’t get that.
The Air also comes with Apple’s new T2 Chip,
which enables Hey Siri support and takes care
of a lot of tasks like automatic file encryption,
which will help it stay future-proof for years
to come.
However, there’s been a lot of backlash
over it, with many people complaining that
the T2 chip blocks third-party shops from
doing repairs on it, but to me, it’s not
a big deal at all.
So which one should you buy?
Well, if you care about performance, especially
graphics performance, then definitely buy
the Pro.
If you use MacBook outside or constantly set
your brightness to max, then definitely buy
the Pro.
If you’re big on portability, honestly,
there’s not much a difference.
They’ll both still fit in the same carrying
case and you won’t really notice the difference
in weight.
If you absolutely must get the best battery
life, then the Air is the obvious choice,
and if you do tons of typing every day, then
the Air will be more comfortable, but I own
a MacBook Pro and the edge doesn’t really
bother me, and I do love the larger trackpad
on the Pro as well.
Another plus for the Air is that the keyboard
will be more reliable thanks to the silicon
barrier, and if you love having loud and clear
speakers, the Pro wins there.
Touch ID is nice, but I honestly don’t think
it’s a big enough deal to affect someone’s
decision.
The T2 chip is nice, but I don’t think it’s
a big deal either, and I basically never use
the Hey Siri function on my new 2018 MacBook
Pro.
So if you’re still having a hard time deciding
which model to buy, tally up all of the things
I mentioned and whether they’re important
to you or not, and then just buy the one that
gets the most points.
We’ve got links to both in the video description,
including the link to the hundred dollars
off MacBook Pro sale, but it’s only for
a limited time, so make your decision quick!
This has been Vadim with Max Tech, make sure
to subscribe and we’ll see you in the next
one!